good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday and today the news is that noted
Alaskan governor Sarah Palin has
announced her resignation being the
expert in Alaskan politics that I am I
am going to tell you four reasons why
she may have quit like her or hater
Sarah Palin is not your usual politician
so let's begin with possibility one she
resigned for the reasons that she cited
in her resignation speech which by the
way would be almost unprecedented in the
history of American resignation speeches
now in the speech she said that she
thought that it was bad for Alaska for
her to be the relentless focus of ethics
investigations she said she was
frustrated with the media for political
blood sport and being cruel to her
family and she also said she felt that
she could help Alaska more from outside
the governor's office but she didn't
cite any of those things as the reason
she was quitting the reason she cited in
the speech was that she had decided not
to run for governor in 2012 and that
being governor for the rest of her term
would be being a lame duck a lot of
blamed up politicians don't accomplish
much in their last two years in office
ergo the courageous thing to do is to
quit now and Hank that is why in her
speech announcing that she was quitting
governor Palin said that not quitting
would be a quitters way out so the
reason she actually cites for quitting
in the speech is that not quitting would
be quitting although I do want to
quickly point out that you don't become
a lame-duck governor until you announce
that you're not going to run for
re-election which you don't have to do
with 18 months still remaining in your
term so that reasoning doesn't
technically hold up to scrutiny
reason 2 she wants to run for president
this is what a lot of conservative
commentators keep saying but it makes
absolutely no sense to me I mean she
didn't feel compelled to quit her job to
run for vice president so why would she
quit her job to run for president three
years before the election what seems
more likely to me is reason three that
she wants to make money Hank the job of
governor of Alaska pays 125 thousand
dollars a year which isn't nothing but
no joke Hank Sarah Palin could make
$125,000 in five days on the public
speaking circuit now Hank I've never
personally had the opportunity to do
five days worth of work and make my
entire annual salary but there's a
pretty short list of things I wouldn't
willing to do I mean I can only think of
about three things I wouldn't kill
anyone I wouldn't hurt anyone and I
wouldn't get above the third rung on a
ladder then of course I think there's
reason for that governor Palin has some
kind of scandal brewing now like as soon
as you say the word scandal both Palin's
supporters and detractors are like blah
blah blah blah they basically become
giant squids of anger so supporters of
governor Palin let me tell you why it
looks a little bit suspicious Palin told
almost no one that she was resigning in
advance which she did at a hastily
called press conference where she didn't
even read prepared remarks that has
happened before in American politics and
every time it's been because of a
scandal like some politician will have a
hastily called news conference late in
the afternoon at the end of a week and
he'll be like I am resigning from office
to spend more time with my family and
then like a week later it comes out that
they really resigned from office because
they owned like a kitten killing factory
in Indonesia on the other hand Sarah
Palin has frequently shown herself to be
genuine about exactly one thing she is
not your usual politician I'm not saying
that's a good or a bad thing I mean
Chewbacca is not your average politician
either I don't want him to be President
wait yes I do
in fact that would be awesome han Solo
could be his vice president and chief
translator wow that idea is really
exciting to me okay I got to go write
some Chewbacca president fan fiction I'm
gonna state my guess about Palin's
resignation right now I think it is
number four I think there is some
unannounced brewing scandal but I've
been wrong before and if I'm wrong this
time I'll be very happy to admit it hang
I'll see you on Tuesday in the meantime
Chewie for president 2012